[Music]
leffen is weapon is he keeps it to rail
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm not happy until every aspect of
godhood is torn away and there's only
one God and that's like that that's how
I feel
lemon what are you gonna do to hungrybox
right now you already know you already
know
can you imagine buoys going into losers
and top 48 something like good that
would left
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
if I said I wasn't good you know I I was
like anything of course
[Applause]
William leffen Delta was born in
Stockholm Sweden on October 16 1994 like
many modern eSports stars he took two
video games early playing Sonic and
Mario as early as three years old
it was Sonic and the Super Mario and
Mickey Mouse but sonic was his favorite
as four or five year old though he was
old enough to have played melee lessons
first real smash experience came from
Super Smash Bros Brawl on the Wii a game
he was playing mostly online I talked to
one of the best brawl players in Sweden
and he was like he had come to this
place in central Stockholm I was like an
hour away from where I lived and played
brawl when I got there there were only
people playing mainly right but they
were gonna go get a brawl disc but
meanwhile I sat down and I just played
mainly like for the first time in a
really long time and then by like half
an hour later when I actually got like
when we got the brawl disc I I was
really young I was like 15 and I didn't
know anyone so I I kinda wanted to just
keep playing melee but I didn't want to
say that in Sweden leffen had a
reputation that would follow him along
his competitive travels he was abrasive
not afraid of speaking his mind and
extremely blunt to some it came off as
cruel and in some cases
downright on sporting he actually is a
bit of an [ __ ] I'm not gonna lie
about that it definitely is and we let
him know that all the time but it's also
a very very fun guy to hang out
you're never bored laughing fell in love
with melee but he had a long road to
travel if he hoped to reach the top he
was good enough to be great but Sweden
was not exactly the world's hotbed for
pro melee in fact Europe barely played
melee especially when leffen was coming
up and the only Swedish player
constantly proving himself in North
America was Armada who quickly became
Levin's rival as well as practice
partner in 2010 he wanted to play with
me
I was the best in Sweden back then the
first time I ever played our model like
this get is good but he has been playing
for a long time and I think I can beat
him I don't think he's that good the one
thing that no one could deny was that
leffen was quickly taking to the game
and improving faster than anyone could
have expected I mean I already knew I
could be good at games from both counter
ball and Wow and so I never really had
like a lot of people that were always
like oh you know like you can't beat
these people that have been playing way
longer than you and so I came in with a
really cocky attitude which was
obviously something that I took too far
eventually in August 2012 leffen was
threatened with a ban from European
tournaments if he didn't fix his
attitude but he ignored those and
warnings from other European smashers
and tournament organisers that he'd be
pushed out of the community if things
didn't change quickly officially I got
like a warning and a warning it was like
in the off-topic part of a forum where
some people said like you have a warning
or you'll be bad which I was like what
that sounds ridiculous because there was
no precedent for it and it was not like
anyone talked to me in person alongside
Armada left and traveled to North
America for the first time in 2011 for
Genesis to famously it was the first na
tournament our model won and the first
North American tournament ever won by a
non North American player leffen for his
part placed 17th falling to s fat and
s2j I was more surprised by like how
many good people there were than like
how the best the actual deaths were
because I already haven't tasted that
like right
but the peak was but I don't think Eric
fully realized until I went into the
u.s. how many like different states are
how many the P Yard player there is in
every state back home though lesson was
quickly establishing himself as one of
the best players in Europe with top four
finishes at beast two smashers reunion
and H F land for all the while though
his reputation as the scenes villain was
spreading that message yeah if I
couldn't get over there and this is
tight oh that's fine that's fine it's up
what oh oh so scar I guess thought he
was out of stocks he wanted to press
Start to take the stock I say what play
it out leptin wants us win leffen was
getting more aggressive his behavior
spread to popular Smash Bros forum smash
boards where people outside the european
community could see it too he trusted
that the scenes other competitors like
armada were on his side but as he
traveled with him to a pax 2013
the man Levin thought was his friend was
collecting evidence for a case against
him
[Music]
Levin's appearance at Apex 2013 wasn't
anything spectacular he was definitely
one of the best players in Europe but
was still far behind much of what na had
to offer Armada took first place once
again dominating a top eight filled with
the best players in the world leffen
meanwhile placed just outside the top 16
a respectable placement for a young
player but far behind the gods of the
game he looked to top who is going to
fluff this and it goes to Harvey clearly
by the skin of his teeth what a
handshake Mexico's going Sam laughing
shakes his head what ignore a clash
Luckman has nothing to be ashamed off he
did fantastic and when he got home
things got worse Armada the recently
retired face of the melee scene accused
leffen of everything from demoralizing
new players to causing drama to bullying
a player with the hearing disability our
mod had noone known about it and like
why was coaching him on stage and stuff
like that he's like trying to ban me the
whole time so at that time I felt pretty
betrayed
kirmada said that lectins behavior
changed the Swedish smash scene and the
only way to fix it was for Levin to fix
his own behavior of course he ignored
previous warnings leaving the community
with the most drastic option they had in
their arsenal and so on February 9th
2013
after months of discussion around his
behavior leffen was banned from all
European smash tournaments
left and missed out on nearly every
major European tournament in 2014 and he
effectively quits smash for some time
after his band switching over to Marvel
vs. Capcom 3 instead trying to take both
Marvel and Super Smash Bros within a
twit longer he posted in March leffen
apologized for his actions saying that
they were the result of depression and
anxiety leffen was just 15 when he
entered the melee community and came to
view smash as an escape from his
personal issues unfortunately he pointed
out those issues were still manifesting
in Smash much of the community felt that
his apology was sincere and that he was
committed to being a better person
I felt the ban was like unfair and to
this day I still think it was ended
really really poorly even though I do
think I did a lot of bad things
well he wasn't banned in the u.s. leffen
only played one tournament in the States
during his ban that tournament was Evo
2013 where he played Marvel vs. Capcom 3
and entered his first smash tournament
in seven months said this is the end
they dropped to shoot
take that left and when he was finally
unbanned six months later he returned
with gusto just dominating completely
away Joe special this this oh my god
that says very very solid starts from
lesson yeah definitely losing a lot of
Sarah Wow
let me get it off why temple I love them
but I don't know Justin over there ah
smallest man hi laughing that was so
speaking and immediately converting how
many uh pairs is this guy getting oh
what a combo what a combo these punishes
are out of this world
at the taunt come on super smash bros
melee is competitive history is often
defined by eras and the early 2010's
were still part of the era of the five
gods armada mango ppmd mew2king and
hungrybox won nearly every tournament
between
2008 and 2015 but at Apex 2014 leffen
made his name known again by defeating
hungrybox two-to-one in the winner's
quarterfinals in the Crouch for
hungrybox oh oh let me jump down in his
chair hungry bugs and losers bracket
congratulations to leffen hungrybox is
lost to leffen was huge
he was the first god laughs and slayed
and he wouldn't be the last after
placing fourth at Apex leffen returned
home where he brought down his second
god defeating Armada twice at beast for
to win his first major tournament and
his first tournament in Europe since his
ban there paradox so stressed and up
smashed and he winced and he 111's
finally hider Nevada Nevada said that
armada I'd have happened he then came
back to the states to defeat his third
god ppmd at MLG anaheim what again it
took laughing a bit longer to slay his
fourth god but his war pact continued
badly oh it's over it's over wave
national an up smash lippmann is in
winter slide top eight will fight armada
hungrybox in the losers sides clutch man
finally at beast five leffen vanquished
another god defeating mango three to two
then went on to beat armada again
getting his first win at a major
tournament with two gods in attendance
I don't know I don't know I like there's
words in a dictionary and none of them
currently describe accurately how I
haven't really decided yet having beaten
for God's and with a major win under his
belt leffen had only one god left on his
hit list
apex 2015 was the largest melee
tournament ever and all five gods were
in attendance leffen worked his way
through the bracket all the way to the
winners quarterfinals to face off
against the last God standing mu to K
this icy slob coming from youichi King
okay
there's I not the time for swamp you
know what it really is is he's running
it lesson right that's it
bets in and lemon takes it over future
king of three stalker dreamland
weapon has made history well he ended up
placing third his place in Mae Lee's
history was cemented he was the god
slave the only player to triumph over
all five gods and become the first
player good enough to extend the top
five to a top six when it came that far
I it was like finally more than it was
like I did it because to some people it
was only a yearbook to me it was like a
really long time where I didn't actually
manage to beat me to go will get to play
and what I felt on the day so I felt
like I play good the era of the five
gods was over maybe it was lesson who
ended it
levin's tear through smash continued
throughout 2015 with a first place
finish at CEO 2015 his first North
American major victory lucky your CEO
champion oh god the ranks are leffen
Armada mango westballz and then a tie
for fifth with between hungrybox bucks
and Schrute
but after resounding victories over
Armada mew2king and mango over the past
few months
laughing slipped up when faced with
hungrybox at evo 2015 because I can't
tell you whatever said that's it
Alfie's the wrong way and hungrybox
takes it and despite making it into the
top eight he was knocked out by plum
leaving him at fifth place
as the years after his return to smash
continued left ins personality mellowed
out but it never really went away leffen
isn't necessarily a bad person he's just
blunt and says what's on his mind which
can get him into trouble sometimes the
things he says like really pisses me off
this is just so stupid why would you do
this just pop it off I'm smarter than
you I'm better than you he just has this
mentality of I'm a king and you're just
some peasant he shouldn't get away with
it the thing about leffen is that he
sometimes finds a way to come out of
that trouble looking good
take for example his legendary beef with
old school Smasher chillin nude in
October 2014 laughs and took to Twitter
to criticize curse and Team Liquid smash
acquisitions trying to understand why
the teams would sign players he thought
were washed up
chillin responded by telling him to
respect his elders and challenged him to
a money match which leffen was hesitant
to go through with but at paragon
Orlando declared he destroyed chillin I
don't need to say anything everyone
knows what I'm going to say and it's
gonna be 500 but that's how it's going
to be - which chillin responded with the
diss track fool shall be looking
it can contain the ass-whoopin right
when we read a lot the money matches
over that'll be a cuter throw a
controller at Apex 2015 the tournament
where leffen completed his god slaying
quest leffen dismantled chillin laughing
the whole time what's really nice Oh
the final stock fertility is left in a
profit the whole story gave leffen a
reputation as someone who could dish out
the trash talk and more importantly sell
it back it up you have anything you want
to say to the people Bobby
these days the target of his ire is
hungrybox
who is one of the few people standing in
Levin's way of being the best in the
world
hungrybox feels like leffen is an
[ __ ] maybe in two years understand
that sometimes talking [ __ ] and then
getting destroyed for the 15th time in a
row might be the reason need to play
badly while Lefton thinks hungrybox is
faking his whole persona you know that's
I think it was hugs that came up with
that like ten years ago or something the
same that like there's two kinds of
people in this world a sports fans and
people who's met him they don't get
along but much of it stems from lectins
desire to be honest and straightforward
he wants to be seen as the guy who tells
it like it is and won't sugarcoat the
truth
he has opinions and as one of the best
in the world he feels they deserve some
respect
after evo 2015 left and remained a top
six player but things were looking a
little shaky after taking first place at
Super Smash Khan he took fifth a tear to
3:03 oh by yo he wants to be heated yeah
I did 2nd of March 2015
Oh Luke is back and 5th at Paragon Los
Angeles oh and that is that is it yes
this is out of the tournament finishing
at what 5th no this fifth place leffen
was good but not yet the best he had
slain gods sure but he wasn't one of
them and in September 2015 his quest got
a lot harder when he tried to enter the
United States for the big house 5 leffen
was sent back to sweden for lacking a p1
visa leffen was signed by Team solomid
in April which meant that as the
employee of an American company he
needed an athlete's visa to compete in
the states that meant no US tournaments
until the visa was settled leaving
leffen sitting on the sidelines for
months our mana will complain about
peach and puffs and probably went left
and played exclusively European
tournaments for seven months
placing well enough but when he came out
to Canada to playing his first North
American tournament in over half a year
he faltered
well done many were ready to call
Levin's government and forced hiatus the
reason for his sloppier planned
just like his tournament ban held him
back a few years earlier not being able
to play in the US would keep him from
greatness just a little longer but
leffen bounced back after his
disappointing finish at EG LX Levin
defeated mew2king Armada field ladies
and gentlemen let me take sit hungrybox
yes it goes out there it should be
[Applause]
and in the grand finals mango defeating
all four active gods in back-to-back
sets the comeback he beat all four dogs
in the lake with that wind laughs and
reclaimed his place not being able to
play in the u.s. might have kept him
from the coveted number one ranked in
the world but it didn't dull his edge at
least those first few months didn't left
and returned to the u.s. at the big
house six one year after his visa
troubles first began while he sandbagged
at that tournament he wasn't quite able
to find consistency after it either oh
that's that was another really really
disappointing there were some successes
there's the roll though up there there
for left
oh very evasive they're giving up center
stage for survive it might be God only
me yeah it's gonna be it good sob right
there laughs and getting the victory
over mango
so c9 is very young mango finishes in
first place at that tournament there
were strong results to be sure but many
felt that leffen to do better himself
included in Levin's ranking fell to from
third and 2015 to fifth and 2016 down to
sixth in the world in 2017 leffen was
hitting a wall but his skill was still
very apparent
[Music]
notably there are a few top smash
players who have ever stepped outside
their game of choice leffen however has
shown off that the fundamentals that
made him so good at melee do carry over
to other games my fundamentals has
always been because like I'm the type of
player I think that wants to know a
situation fully or like understand fully
and not just like run in and just do
things out of healing leffen played
Street Fighter 4 and Marvel vs. Capcom
earlier on in his career but the game
he's found his most success in outside
of smash is Dragon Ball fighters I had a
son be able to go to a local dinner
when's the next fights and I never
thought like I'm Wayne or anything about
would like maybe get like number 5 we're
like 7th or something like that but
actually ended up winning and beating
everyone and one of the strongest
regions and I think that's when some
people took notice and I also realized
that like I could actually be really
good at this game
lemon is placed well at several
tournaments much higher than many would
expect from someone who's never
seriously competed in a more traditional
fighting game
he placed ninth at CEO where he played
an incredibly close set with fighting
game legend go eat you and go et you
gotta believe that going she came into
this thing and who the heck am i
fighting right now oh my god I just love
when the underdogs he's just serving but
you're adulterated this is like Oh what
world champion in his own right coming
in one
new arena - suet don't even play with
your fool around on the pinky Ponk all
right what a piece somebody's that
they're gonna chop the ball here you
imagine going she's going into losers in
top 48 something like as the reaction of
a 25 year old cedar
oh no coal Mike yeah let them defeat
another guy is he truly the God and
slave I think this is a you still taste
guys
that was close oh my god no that takes
[ __ ] that takes it for me oh that was
the best match of the weekend so far and
third at Canada Cup where he out placed
some of the game's top players sat there
to see his mans go down and then you
know it's been an honour Angela 16
leffen has become the first of the top
smashers to extend his reach past just
melee
there's been plenty of talk over the
years about how long melee can last
given it's nearly two decades old and
relies on dead hardware but lessons
skill at Dragon Ball and other fighters
has shown that his legacy won't end with
melee but leffen doesn't do it for his
legacy he does it to prove he's the best
to prove his skills carry over after a
disappointing Evo 2017 leffen was
looking inconsistent he was still one of
the best still dominant but there were
times where he looked shaky ur top
platform he can't stand the top off the
top the double up here off the top and
to defeat the like me but the valley did
eventually give way to another peak he
won a handful of small tournaments here
and there as 2018 began but any major
any tournament with more than one god in
attendance left laughing in second third
even fifth
[Applause]
[Music]
never stones stones own until Evo
leading up to Evo many people felt it
was nearly anybody's tournament
hungrybox was the best in the world but
our motto was regaining his form mango
was playing well and plop was looking
like a powerful dark horse contender Oh
laughing as always was a shoo-in for top
eight but once there he provided a
surprise upset for the audience I guess
if I'm bluffing at this point so I mean
Levin is a very very fierce competitor
even when he was not like that even when
he was not as good as he was today right
he wanted to be the best you know he's
that's his mission one set is try to be
the best in the world
[Music]
right so you could be okay gets it hbox
not able to smash the oddities up their
uppers right now moment you know no harm
no foul
that's right let me catch up flip it
theoretically you know a star for fruits
that have uh put him in the mouth that's
a little bit of a mistake
Leavitt probably you know it could come
back to bite him but the way this is
going it might just not bad after like
losing three socks and probably the
first minute of the said that was Lefton
collects himself wins a tight game two
in a scrap situation and then Game three
so he blows them out of the water what
was that and after beating hungrybox
leffen faced off against pluck a player
who had often gone the better of heaven
wants to go up to oh yeah there it is
bad might be it
no tech was there though cause he
expected about there a bursary up here I
expected end up here - yeah yeah what
it's worth now cap should be vote oh
okay backers one more time and the board
smash ready to response attack dad no
chump for flop that's gonna do it
a little small no God like that he grabs
the legend of the framebuffer plug it up
he wins the race everything again the
same exact thing captain's to Scotts
narrow club on able to grab the ledge
doing the impossible leffen was given
his spot in the grand finals on the
winner side there
he faced off against Armada his friend
his Swedish rival the man who betrayed
him all those years ago
and the only person left standing
between him and a title he'd wanted for
so long - getting out of the pressure
he's got a knockdown amount of text but
let them react Toronto leopards
reactions right oh so fun point yeah
no model doesn't touch the platform go
support it but yep nothing's ready for
it oh no one behind mark question mark
left for just less adjusted the lender
life that's a bet he just hit the less
he's Nesbitt got it down like a sold a
threeway - fine from 11:00 it's like
perfectly timed and perfectly the
distance yeah they'll punish that the
whiff punished on a lagless move my word
flow play chase down man when I said
lagless I don't belittle there but like
that that is a very very difficult for
here to punish on the action we are
still playing more man
this is armadas last song will he come
alive for his Levin too powerful 8% come
up Armada has no shield absolutely
tearing through everyone today told
weapon is our evil 2018 super smash
brothers melee champion pull open
[Applause]
oh my god seriously lettin a man who's
you know really the tale of the
anti-hero
to help us take on existential threats
and save the world right that is the
story of weapon and that is the feeling
and emotion that he is choking up right
now
finally throughout this year melee I had
been like incredibly cuz it's the
moccasins that I've ever been before but
I've never actually got the wind which
was really annoying for me and to win
IVA specifically was always a big like
eventually became a big goal by an just
because it was the tournament that I
always did the worst at and it was like
more than anything like oh I won't even
finally and like common even champion
was just like I finally like managed to
not get tilted by myself and like
managed to overcome myself and play
really good melee leffen had done it he
won melees biggest tournament on
fighting games his biggest stage the
Godslayer finally killed the last legacy
of melees old gods
leffen didn't begin his career as the
villain but as heroes his personality
created a backlash that has followed him
to this day
he has his fans certainly but he also
still has his haters those that still
hold a grudge against him for speaking
his mind for being blunt even for being
perceived as rude to other players but
leffen doesn't stand alone he stands
amidst a community that has learned to
respect him that has learned that every
community needs someone willing to tell
it like it is to ignore the social order
and just say what people are thinking
left and went from villain to validate
his skill improved and improved until he
did the impossible and after doing that
he still wanted more he still went
further
he's melees first Evo champion that's
not one of the five gods he's more than
just the god Slayer he's the next
generation
he was melees first new legend and his
rise is not yet complete
thanks for watching if you want more
great content just like this be sure to
hit the subscribe button
[Music]